on this episode I sneak up on Johanna
because she was trying to duck it hi
don't ever try to duck it I won't do
that ever again good that's what I do on
this episode
[Music]
this is
Gary B
I've literally lost the intro to this
show in my brain thank you guys
some illegal 1:55 ready yep everybody
this is gary vay-ner-chuk and this is
episode 155 of the askgaryvee show
hey everyone sorry sorry I do your thing
sorry guys
look at the Matt's Jersey in the
background I like that book 55 double
nickels super happy to be on 15 which i
think is a really you know some nice
number place ones and fives india ones
and fives on this friday will give my
jets official prediction at the end i
know a lot of you've been waiting now
that i'm 5 for 5 people have really been
building up just a phone's gonna bet is
what I hear that's what I hear that's
what I heard
India let's get into the show manake ask
what do you think of slack as a
Productivity environment for startups
I've not used slack yet though Bainer
has used it at scale hi guys like in
slack so far anybody using good solid
good yeah people love it like it's an
incredible incredible product I'm a huge
fan of Stewart Butterfield who's behind
the product built Flickr and was a very
much a web 2.0 hero of mine because
Flickr was one of the first sites that
got me aware of this revolution that got
me into the world so I have a lot of
emotional heart for slack I haven't used
it yet because I've been running around
so much big so I don't think I can
necessarily answer this question India
and my lack of practitioner ship what I
do though though is by that quick little
reaction know if you caught it on camera
but did you do rock a little bit or kind
of so people are obsessed with this
goddamn product I don't know how much
you guys I know some and yeah I mean so
what do you think India less emails
because they kind of just like hang in
flat
and it's easier to just ask for
something really offhand to the little
team instead of having to like send an
email and compose it it's kind of like
it's kind of like the it's kind of like
the lovechild of like email and like
group me right and so I think there's
some real value behind I haven't jammed
yet so I don't want to necessarily go
deep into this and one of the things I
adore about this show is I talk about
[ __ ] I know and so I've got my feelings
as you can tell like I can give
analogies like the group meet you know
thing and I know what's going on I see
the feedback loop I have a lot of
contact from a lot of other people but
I'm not a dead user of it but on my two
cents on it is um um yeah I'm bullish on
it I think there's something there no I
was I was trying to see the but I say
was the next question so I phased it out
Liana I could sit down over here now
Liana yeah cool Liana ass you talked a
lot about serendipity was there one
event that made you a believer or a
series of occurrences Liana it there's
no one event beyond a certainty please
life it's how things work and there was
no singular event on the gold this was
so serendipitous I'm such a big believer
in serendipity now serendipity is just a
structural aspect of the way our world
works I mean chances an absolute part of
it it's the way it is and so no there
was no there was no event it was clearly
a series of events that all probably
started happening when I was five or six
years old when I started paying
attention to things and so it's a it's
it's more of a collective believe it's
like it's like I almost think of it as
like my belief in oxygen like it's just
there right it's just real and it's just
certain if it is real India [ __ ] is real
what about your answer yesterday about
timing and talent do you think timing is
how they do it serendipity you know I
definitely believe in serendipity and
luck right like I believe in those
things like those are real things too
but I don't think everything is one
thing or the other I definitely think
you can prep for opportunity I mean
these are all semantics you know I mean
now we're nitpicking like like clearly
doing the right thing and getting
yourself in the right places and
educating yourself and testing things
and setting yourself up for victory
clearly those are real things
but clearly other things factored into
it right so it's just a combination of
like science and art I always think
about or just you know that the black
away in the gray I mean this is this is
literally a thesis of everything and I
and I xx it's like you know tastes great
less feeling people feel like they have
they like pick a spot I mean they're
both right and so for me the question
becomes actually if you're lucky enough
to self-awareness can you bet on one or
the other like that's what the reason I
love gray so much or talk about all the
things I believe in this because it's
what comes natural to me it's where my
upside lies
I believe in like taking notes and
studying in all that [ __ ] it's just not
for me I wouldn't have the maximize
upside for it Thank You India Dustin
Destin like to have yeah like that
Destin Destin Vaynerchuk I would have
dominated as a destined opt I was making
pretend if my name was destiny
what's India Destin ass what's the best
way to start a business in a space that
you're unfamiliar with but see massive
opportunity in become educated you know
I I hear that you know what there's a
great question I'm glad you asked that
it was a question that was asked a lot
of me in two thousand six seven eight
nine that I haven't heard in a while
maybe because India is doing the picking
and so you know I I think that if you
see a huge opportunity if you think
eSports is gonna be a huge space like
I'd believe well then maybe you go
intern for an eSports company maybe get
a job at eSports company maybe you read
absolutely everything about it that was
one of my few chapters in life that's
what web 2.0 thing bact just flick ER
like I read everything on TechCrunch I
read you know people tweets I it was one
time when I actually consumed because I
needed to get educated and then once I
found I had the base then I rolled back
to where I normally go but you put in
the work you know if you see a space you
become massively educated you network in
it tremendously I believed in online
video in 2006 I went to three meetups in
the video 2.0 or the video wasn't called
whoa yeah web 2.0 video meetup group
d-roc you would've been so proud I went
to these damn singing people talking
about [ __ ] cameras and lighting up
that it's the content mother
you know but like it was you know it was
it was really he you like that it was a
it was a an interesting time for me when
I was soaking up information if you see
an opportunity go soak up the
information go become a practitioner go
work in a company in it go to all the
events around it read about it go to
conferences and listen about it listen
to the podcasts like learn learn about
it I like that you get advice to hear
learn about it and then you can do but
you know if you believe in something you
have to become educated in it and then
become a practitioner in it and then
execute in it and then adjust to the
realities of it destined and then you've
got just kidding Jake asks why did you
go to college Jake that's such a good
question because my my parents peer
pressured me into that [ __ ] they're
like there was just no option it was
back in 92 3 4
you know like they they expected it
would have been embarrassing had I not
gone that was just the truth like I had
by the way I had the reason I ended up
in Mount Ida College is because I had no
plans of going to college like there was
a no I didn't go to see my guidance
counselor I don't even know why God's
counselors name I I think I think I sort
of once in 40 years right so like I went
because because my parents wanted me to
go like it's really sent my mom just
didn't I don't think she would have
known how to answer the question of like
why didn't he there was so much social
peer pressure at that point then if you
did not go you were such a fundamental
loser and it's so different now probably
why I have so much passion for it
because if you don't think that I think
that I would be further along and
happier and happier
not just and look I mean some great
friends and have some great times but
like four years damn it ninety four or
five and six seven like doing that web
1.0 bubble Richard she Richard a lot hey
Gary its Richard lalonde here and I'm
developing a short film about you as a
child and your entrepreneurial chops
okay and my question for you is at what
age did you decide that you want to buy
the New York Jets that's a great
question I think the age when I really
decided I wanted buy the Jets was
somewhere around I don't know exactly
what shirt to be honest with you so I
think it's somewhere around fourth fifth
sixth grade when I realized that I was
more likely to buy them than to play for
them and I started seeing other kids
growing a little bit faster than I was
growing being a little bit faster
wakil shaw fifth grade walk heel shaw i
think gave me one of my first my first
previews into being owner and not player
because he was a beast and he ran over
me in backyard football so making a lot
of old school references by the way made
that bode ed weinstock reference with
peter yesterday a friend for mine from
middle school hit me up and he's like oh
my god dad so like i was kind of fun
wakil anybody when Martin Luther King
nineteen eighty-two to eighty-five
Edison New Jersey Martin Luther King
elementary school knows the name wakil
Shaw if you know wakil shaw find him and
say what's actually it's so easy just
search on Faceman that ridiculous he
moved I think the Baltimore area anyway
yeah Richard that's the answer and I
think to make this more of an
interesting answer for everybody who's
watching which I'm gonna start doing
more of the one thing I'm gonna start
doing India's when these answers are fun
the fun question or what have you I'm
gonna try to go a little bit broad if
you are lucky enough right now to have a
younger sibling a niece or nephew a
cousin or if you're the parent of a
child of that is as early as six seven
eight nine ten years old really starts
talking about what they want to do for a
living please please please think about
how to put them in the best position to
succeed the kids the children are our
future India
they're our future and so um I I think
you know and that's sure I want to be a
baseball player and you may not think
they're athletic enough and I get that
and then and then so the question
becomes you send them to baseball camp
or do you actually look at them and say
look you know me and mom are five foot
four you're not gonna become a baseball
player one day but can you start showing
them other parts of baseball right can
they become a future amazing GM or
manager things that nature I think we
need to do better jobs at a really
reverse-engineering the child that over
indexes in disproportionate passion not
the flavor of the month but has shown
two three four years of consistent
conversation around a hobby or subject
matter there's so much we could be doing
with them in those years where they have
a lot of time impressionable moldable
that can be very powerful so please take
it on yourself to be responsible to
sniff out the youngmee's of the world
who really never waivered who we're all
in didn't pivot didn't change their
passions and and and try to put them in
that position thank you you too Brad
yeah we kind of talked about it
yesterday I mean look the YouTube red
things super interesting you team needs
to make money here's another thing about
YouTube red I think that tons of humans
and thousands and hundreds of thousands
of businesses have made a shitload of
money on the YouTube ecosystem and
YouTube has it nothing's broken
for YouTube so I think they need to fix
it and that's why we're seeing it and
you can cry about it and you can have
your panties in a bunch and you can do
whatever you want but the but like but
the bottom line is they've got to do
that because if you - doesn't make money
then it shuts down India and then were
you gonna go with you know what were you
gonna go India you're not good yeah
you're not gonna can't go through the
wall and you can't go on YouTube if they
go out of business so you get our but
that's the bottom line that's what I
think it's it's not Noble and it's not
the Zen thing but like if they go out of
business where you going
what are you gonna go somewhere else
someone else that's gonna make money
because I'm like and I'm not gonna do it
YouTube's way we lost money that way
okay prediction time so I will say this
and you've watched five episodes so all
of you I don't want to hear like I don't
hedge I don't hedge but I'm hedging
meaning this is clearly the game
unleased I'm most confused about the
reason I think I drilled the last five
was I was completely confident I know
the matchups I know what's going on and
I felt confident that's why I went five
for five this one I'm not as confident
about I don't know exactly what's gonna
happen I heard amazing news that buster
screens gonna play that's huge because
he's our best slot receiver coverage man
and I'm pumped because I love Buster
bust so with Buster in mind I'm changing
the prediction a little bit but I'm
gonna still unfortunately go
27:16 Patriots you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering
[Music]